Ozlem sent me this £6 postcard from Turkey...
...where she asked me if I had ever tried authentic Turkish coffee.
And I hadn't.
So I headed over to Izmir, Turkey...
...to try the coffee that Ozlem says she absolutely adores.
Izmir is Turkey's third largest city with three million people.
It's known to ancient history as the City of Smyrna...
...with 3,500 years of recorded human history.
It's a center of art, culture, modernity and progressivism within Turkey.
And it's considered one of Turkey's most forward-thinking cities.
I chose it because its old town has a very high concentration of cafes and shops,...
...many of which serve authentic Turkish coffee.